I was incarcerated overnight for eight
months in a confinement facility not if
you were in jail yeah I was in jail now
not a not a normal prison but it's
called a confinement Center but yeah you
can't leave and I'm in a bunk bed it's
just like Danbury right I'm in a bunk
bed with like 60 hardened criminals get
out of here oh yeah so I did I did my
eight months I was done with all that
this is in what year this was in 2000 uh
uh 13. okay yeah and then
um and then I'm done with that but I'm
still on probation and I still you know
like if I travel like my passport gets
dinged I gotta go to a special room so
my point is I was still quote under
scrutiny so when Trump pardoned me I was
doing community service and I was on
probation but I'd actually served my
quote sentence uh but the pardon cleared
my record I mean I can now vote I can
own a gun I mean had you ever been to
jail before in your life prior to that
well you I think you can kind of imagine
the answer is obviously no okay you're
right I mean no I mean I didn't to me I
was like yeah yeah but I don't know if
you know now when he got out he had an
RNC tattoo here at 1776. do you want to
show it to everybody
wow I mean even criminals do you
do here and these conversations to me
were like laugh out loud funny because
I'd be like well you know I was I
violated the campaign Finance well
paying Finance law yeah so I go well
there's a campaign Finance is that like
carjacking I go you know I gave away too
much of my own money they're like buzz
they're like you mean you didn't take
somebody else's money you're giving
money your money I'm like yeah you're
here for that they couldn't even believe
it so eight months so back to the Trump
pardon he calls you you get a letter and
then like you get to uh yeah communicate
with him break that down he calls me uh
well Ted Cruz was the one who asked him
he goes you got a part in Dinesh and
literally Trump was like hmm done it was
like that wow yeah and then Trump tells
uh John Kelly who was in the chief of
staff you know work it out now I didn't
hear anything for 60 days because they
do a check they run a legal review they
do a few things but then Ted Cruz calls
me and he goes head in there she goes
you got your cell phone on you he goes I
got some interesting news he goes the
White House just called asking for your
phone number so you better keep your
cell phone like on on because they're
likely to call you in the next like 60
minutes and you can't call them back
so sure enough I got the call from Trump
and um and we talked for about 10
minutes on the phone he called you
personally yeah hey Dinesh yeah djt here
you know he uses his phone a lot he's
the guy that uses a smartphone that you
were getting out of jail all right well
he's also very casual he's like I'm here
with John Kelly he's like you know you
know John Kelly know you I'm like no I
mean I know he's the chief of staff but
I don't know General John Kelly General
John Kelly and then we know we talked a
little bit about the situation and he's
like Hey listen I'm gonna sign you a
pardon in the morning and but you know
the tweeting he goes he goes listen
don't tell anybody about it let me tweet
about it first he did say that and so it
was announced to the world buy a tweet
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you foreign
[Music]